cette vidéo a été publiée sur télégramme
par le gouverneur pro russe de la région
on y aperçoit
l'intérieur de la centrale de zaporizhya
et les dégâts causés par les obus qui se
sont récemment abattues sur le site
nucléaire quelques rares clichés
montrent la centrale enveloppé d'un
nuage de fumée la zone a bien été le
théâtre ces derniers jours
d'affrontements entre ukrainiens russes
-les agences ukrainiennes de l'énergie
atomique annonce que l'un de ses
employés a été blessés dans de nouveaux
tirs samedi soir
mais la situation reste floue car les
belligérants se rejettent la
responsabilité
qui a fait waucampt des bombardements
russes tandis que moscou met en cause
des tirs d'artillerie ukrainien une
chose est sûre une ligne de haute
tension a été endommagée sur ce site
nucléaire occupée par les forces russes
l'un des trois réacteurs encore en état
de marche c'était un automatiquement
mais le risque d'incident n'est pas
écartée les bombardements ont gravement
endommagé une station renfermant de la
zot et de l'oxygène et un bâtiment
auxiliaire il existe toujours des
risques de fuites d'hydrogène et de
substances radioactives et le risque d'
incendies est également élevé
la même inquiétude au sein de l' agence
internationale pour l'énergie atomique
samedi dans un communiqué les yeux à
faisait part d'informations alarmantes
sur la situation à sa politique a évoqué
un risque réel de catastrophe nucléaire
son directeur général veux tu y déployer
une mission d'experts mais se demande
sont jusqu'ici restées lettre morte de
son côté l'union européenne accuse la
russie de mener des activités militaires
autour de la centrale en violation des
règles de sécurité nucléaire les
occupants russes s'étaient emparés du
complexe de zappos dj en mars dernier et
avaient ouvert le feu sur des bâtiments
du site faisant craindre le risque d'un
accident nucléaire majeur